over the past generation brands have
shifted from simply static images to
dynamic system this three-part series
entitled the 22nd century brand is
brought to you by design Singapore the
national agency for design enabling
Singapore to use design for economic
growth and to improve lives in these
discussions we will be looking at the
origin of Brad's how brands function in
our contemporary cultural landscape and
the future of brands where it's all
headed my name is hunter Tara I'm the
founder and CEO of an international
brand design consultancy called
syndicate acts over the past 25 years
I've had the opportunity to work with
some of the world's leading
organizations across culture commerce
and technology and I've helped them
develop clear brand stories and I've
helped them articulate their value
proposition I've worked with
multinational corporations such as
Netflix Nike GE Unilever Lululemon OD
and Asics - some of the world's leading
museums and cultural institutions
including the Victoria and Albert Museum
and the John F Kennedy Center for the
Performing Arts through these
collaborative partnerships I've had the
opportunity to see how brands really
work and to witness the power they have
in our collective consciousness this
series is intended to share some of the
insights and secrets I've been able to
gather over the course of my career in
our last discussion we looked at the
origin of brass
tracing their cultural meaning from
ancient Rome through the advent of the
21st century in this installment we're
going to examine the role of brands in
our contemporary cultural landscape and
our collective consciousness and examine
the dynamics shift from static brand
identities to a new set of phenomena
whereby brands themselves have now
become the focal point for interaction
and transaction we're also going to
explore how the role of the designer is
changing in this contemporary context
especially with the rise of
sophisticated technologies data and
artificial intelligence over the past
generation brands have shifted from
simply static images to dynamic systems
where every part of an organizational
image and reputation is designed the
shift is due in part to the ability of
designers to achieve levels of visual
sophistication through digital
technology that was previously not
possible but it also corresponds with a
fundamental change in global culture and
commerce as globalized organizations
became more intricate they increasingly
relied on new design techniques to
manage this complexity brands more than
ever rely on a complex set of
partnerships associations and
affiliations which means they need a new
set of devices and a new set of tools
both visually as well as in terms of the
nomenclature and language that they use
to remain clear an increasingly crowded
and complex marketplace for example if
we consider the case of GE under the
leadership of CEO Jack Welch during the
1990s a company that had previously
produced household electronics
lightbulbs toasters
now owned a television network an
investment bank a jet engine division
medical imaging devices and wind
turbines who's an incredibly broad and
varied corporate entity but to make
sense of a company like GE as a single
organization designers now needed a new
set of flexible approaches to present a
coherent image of the company one that
would be recognizable for both end-users
and the investment community this has
led to a whole new Lexus con in the
world of brands and a virtual science of
branding itself companies and
organizations now need to express their
mission vision and values and establish
their visual hierarchy through brand
architecture and messaging guidelines
with the rise of the new economy in the
1990s and through the runners of at
based businesses which came to the
forefront with the global prevalence of
the iPhone first released in 2007 the
nature of branding and brands has
fundamentally shifted once again whereas
older brands were primarily an image
which stood for a set of principles
today the brand itself has become a
platform for participation and exchange
[Music]
first of all what does it mean for brand
to be participatory for me this is the
first and most important distinction
from the traditional logic of branding
now brands themselves facilitate and
encourage action in the case of Airbnb
is to belong anywhere for tik-tok is to
inspire creativity and bring joy for
Twitter it's to give everyone everywhere
the power to create and share ideas
for Facebook it's to give people the
power to build community and bring the
world closer together
[Music]
for LinkedIn to connect the world's
professionals to make them more
productive and successful and of course
for Google to organize the world's
information and make it universally
accessible useful
each of these brands are built to be
participatory in some way there is a
clear call to action and an invitation
to participate the more people who
participate the richer the brand
experience and the more robust the
platform we each have our own profiles
and we interact with friends and
strangers alike through their digital
platforms the second part of the
contemporary brand is exchange
what does exchange mean in this context
well all brands have always been
transactional in other words goods and
services have always been bought and
sold today brands encourage exchange on
a higher order everything from social
networking to the sharing of content all
the way to buying and selling and even
trading and bartering more archaic forms
of transaction have become modern again
well there is undeniably a sophisticated
technology at work it is in the space of
the brand where all of the action
actually happens and through Facebook's
mission the technology encourages me to
connect with a broad series of friends
and friends of friends all within the
safe space of the Facebook Brad
Uber's mission is to bring
transportation for everyone everywhere
in other words their mission is to
connect people indeed today every like
every food order every purchase every
friend request
we birthday photo every mean post exists
within the confines of a brand and the
more of us who participate in exchange
the richer that brand experience becomes
this has given brands and even deeper
role in our everyday lives and in
certain cases has displaced more
traditional forms of human interaction
it has given brands an incredible power
over our consciousness and in many cases
uber being a fantastic example of how
the boundaries have blurred in terms of
how we engage brands a single person can
now be an employee a customer and an
ambassador for a brand and even more
strangely fulfill the same roles for a
competitive brand simultaneously think
of an uber driver who also works for
lyft and Juno at the same time this is
both an incredibly exciting and an
incredibly scary time for brad's and the
question is how do they remain relevant
and mission driven in this increasingly
disruptive landscape and what does it
mean for the designer whose role has
shifted from the 20th century ideal of
the author to today that of an editor or
a curator or even an impresario
first off there has never been a better
time to be a designer global brands
certainly led by the example of Apple
have given the broader public a deeper
understanding how great design can
impact our lives and how design can make
a positive impact in the world moreover
to be a designer today means not just
working on architecture or visual
identities or fashion or websites
increasingly it means working across
these media simultaneously to ensure the
consistency of the brand design across
all public facing touch points the idea
of the designer today is more expansive
than at any point in history all of that
said how designers work and even if they
work is changing first the rise of
artificial intelligence has meant that
there are now online platforms think of
the Wix logo maker that can generate a
professional-looking brand by answering
just a few questions and clicks of the
mouse
next globalization and the ability to
seamlessly collaborate through online
platforms has meant that companies and
organizations can work with any designer
anywhere including parts of the world
that are far less expensive than the
traditional design at the Centers of New
York London Amsterdam Milan and Tokyo in
the Kovan 19 world I'm working with
project teams in Singapore Madrid London
New York and Dusseldorf on a daily basis
without ever having to leave my home and
lastly the rise of design thinking over
the past decade has meant that large
corporations have now internalized
design functions within their
organizations twenty-five years ago it
was quite rare to have a design
counterpart a client-side today it's
even more rare for a company to not have
someone with a design background
managing their brand communications
advertising and media but for all of the
societal changes that present challenges
for designers there are also the
corresponding set of new opportunities
today designers have to understand
global systems information technology
the global flow of capital and local
business customs in addition to a clear
understanding of form color composition
and hierarchy and of course designers
today can be their own entrepreneurs
controlling the means of production in
certain cases we don't need clients at
all paradoxically today the designer is
more integral and simultaneously more
disposable than ever before
and plays a larger role in the creation
development maintenance and management
of brands and what does the current
global pandemic mean for brands today
and moving forward and how do we as
designers position ourselves to gain the
necessary skills and anticipate the
brand challenges of tomorrow the next
installment called the future of brands
will give us a clue as to how brands
will be different in the future what
that means for us as designers
[Music]